(bright theme music)
- Here's a tip guaranteed to make life
all a little more beautiful.
- From artist, Helen Dealtry,
you've gotta watch this.
- A journal or a sketchbook
is a really good way
to start sort of pulling
these things together
and forming your own styling,
getting to know yourself and over time,
you'll get used to doing something,
maybe like a mood board.
This is something that I begin
before I start any project.
And usually, I'm creating for a client
or I'm doing a set of paintings,
so it could be like eight paintings.
And I know that before I begin
I really wanna get my palette started.
I wanna get excited about
what I'm gonna be painting.
So I start gathering
and I start collecting
and I start laying things down.
We're not actually going to be
painting any of these things
but we want to build the foundation
and figure out a color
palette and get inspired.
And the way I typically work is by
moving around the board
with color and form
and just placing things so
that they please me visually,
'cause I'm the only one seeing this.
And it's just so that when
you come in, in the morning,
it gets you sort of excited,
it gets you sort of,
the brain starts sparking with ideas.
- I love Helen.
Chip and Joanna, where
can I get more of Helen?
- She hosts Art In Bloom
on Magnolia Network,
where she shares the
making of her beautiful
original creations.
- I love it.
(bright music)